more allegations are being revealed
about accused sex predator and alleged
cult leader Nathan chasing horse the
question will the criminal case against
him help raise awareness about a cause
to help protect individuals in Native
communities a news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy explores the issue
of course they also want attention on
the mmiw movement that's for murdered
and missing indigenous women and also
children that should never have happened
to that poor baby Jason Smith's story
striking Accord with Simona bear cub his
son Justice Smith Hilton died after the
family had turned to Nathan chasing
horse I lost my best friend Smith says
he claims he was a medicine man who
could cure his son's cancer bear cub is
a mother grandmother and Advocate she
says she's also a friend of one of
chasing horses survivors
six-year-old Dances with Wolves actor is
in jail in Las Vegas for 19 charges
including sex crimes against children
when it came out the first thing I
thought was it's about time
some Advocates are saying it's also
about time the mmiw movement gets the
attention it deserves Alison Renville is
a Lakota media consultant we have
something happen to us and it's
devastating and it feels like we need
Justice and we need all these things and
um
it's hard to even trust that someone's
going to believe them or not use it
against them we need to stop it bear cub
says she's had her own experience with a
predator like chasing horse with victims
shaming blaming and the personal
struggle to process the trauma she knows
firsthand the challenge in speaking up
she and Renville say they're trying to
create a safe space in a community which
has been ignored that means hope
it means
um fighting back to protect women and
children like justice he deserved better
Vanessa Murphy 8 News Now